on the road to hakive a line of cars
full of people escaping the horrors of
War weighed down by their belongings and
the memories of what they've lived
through
our house was burned this night the
house burned and all that was inside we
have no place to stay it is scary
they're coming from the nearby Village
of roscolesova which has been under
Russian occupation for more than a month
Fierce battles or Russian troops pushed
back and Ukraine's forces regain full
control of the village the basement was
shaking from the explosions we were
screaming we were crying and we were
praying to God but they're arriving in
hakith which itself has come under near
daily bombardment since Russia's
Invasion began it looks less like a city
more like a collection of mangled
buildings
local Fighters do what they can to
protect their neighbors
when your city is being destroyed when
your close people are being killed there
is no other option but to defend them
but they say they feel helpless against
Russia's fighting Power forced to stand
by as missiles rain down
ukrainians forced to escape the conflict
are also arriving in separation seen as
a gateway to Ukrainian territory from
occupied areas in the South
we all have relatives abroad in Russia
as well we used to love this country so
much it's very hard for me to speak
about this since it's as if as if a man
attacked his own brother this is very
painful
Ukraine's President says he remains open
to peace talks but he's warned that
negotiations are close to collapse
because of Russia's continued aggression
he says ukrainians are in the fight of
their lives
when the Russians confirm something such
as a prisoner exchange I don't believe
in it they confirm some kind of civil
exchange and then something goes wrong
once twice three times the risks that
negotiations will be cut off entirely
are very high
U.S accuses Russia's President Vladimir
Putin of depravity in his invasion but
Russia's foreign minister Sergey levrov
says the West is at fault and that NATO
countries are doing everything they can
to prevent a ceasefire by sending
weapons to Ukraine
until a deal is reached the fighting
rages on
Alexia O'Brien Al Jazeera